for families with school-aged kids it's
been a difficult fall we've been sick
basically for three months since we've
been back into school with viral
illnesses like covet RSV and the flu
surging schools are seeing student
absence levels rise staff are getting
sick too but no matter how bad it gets
Alberta schools will no longer be able
to move online Alberta's education
Minister announced Thursday schools must
ensure quote access to in-person
learning even when high numbers of
students and staff are sick also saying
students cannot be denied in-person
learning due to their decision to wear
or not wear a mask that's a recognition
that we've been asking for and school
divisions across this province have been
asking for is that Health decisions need
to be made by Health officials the virus
appears to have arrived several weeks
earlier than a normal flu season and the
growth rate or the number of cases
increasing per week is again on a scale
we really haven't seen in in recent
memory and with Children's Hospitals
already Under Pressure this infectious
diseases researcher believes Public
Health measures will be necessary at
some point soon whether those measures
take place in schools or someplace else
it's a tough one because I know if I
have a four-year-old and if my kid had
immune system problems
I would probably be one of those
hypersensitive parents there's a little
bit
uh worrying especially that kids are
getting so sick and uh mask kind of our
only
Surefire way to protect what little
space we have especially in the
classroom even without mandates Health
officials are encouraging mask use again
urging everyone to get the covid and flu
vaccines to this flu season may not Peak
until early next year Heather your ex
West Global News Calgary